all right look at the new york jets
first round pick since 2012 not good at
all
traded traded traded traded traded since
2013. unbelievable
so now sam darnold traded after they
traded up from six to three to get him
they gave up three second round picks to
make the trade up they get a second
round pick a fourth round pick in the
sixth round pick to move on
from him so
let's draft man what that's crazy there
that that graphic because the three guys
that are actually good aren't they
didn't keep them they're not on their
team that's that's what's even funnier
about that well because they didn't want
to pay him that's what he came down to
they didn't want to pay him they
realized they didn't want to pay
all right you're up first uh most
disappointing just jets quarterbacks of
all time go well i think i'll start off
with richard todd i mean richard todd
came in as the heir apparent for joe
namath everybody thought he was going to
be the savior of the organization that
type of guy came from alabama just like
joe namath was coached by bear bryant
he's a superstar can't miss type guy and
of course it was a disaster he threw
more interceptions than touchdowns you
know he's famous of course i can still
remember one of the first stories i ever
heard about him was he was the guy that
threw steve serby the great new york
sports writer into a locker right over
some disagreement or i can't remember i
think it was like maybe serbia wrote an
article about the backup quarterback
should play or something like that but
uh that even though that was before my
time even as a young boy i knew the name
richard todd and that it wasn't a good
thing so i'll go with that as my first
that's just funny as you're growing up
toddling around the house you know when
you hear richard todd that is a signifi
an indication that the guy bill sims is
turning into richard todd who's that dad
oh some stinky quarterback oh they're
saying they're gonna be like them come
on man pick up your pick up your play
you know there's so many different ways
i can go here
um
i gotta go neal o'donnell just because
he came in as a free agent with a big
contract yeah with a ton of expectations
a ton of hype and he just flat out stunk
and uh that that isn't that the only
foray into a major long-term multi-year
quarterback contract that the jets have
made where they expected we're signing
this guy right out of the gates super
bowl quarterback and and the steelers
are like go ahead you can take go ahead
please you have have fun you can you can
have him and it just it was a disaster
for him and for the jets and that was
that for neil o'donnell yeah there was
great expectations i mean yeah coming
from the steelers the super bowl team
you just thought oh man this will be
great he'll give them a little you know
help but you know just just like we talk
about with a lot of these quarterbacks
there's just not a lot of support there
by the team to help out any of these
damn quarterbacks out but yeah the neil
o'donov neil o'donnell experiment was
quick and uh wasn't that good that's for
sure
um
man i'm not sure what i'm gonna go with
here all right i mean i i guess i'm
gonna go with browning nagel i'm gonna
go yes yes going with brownie [ __ ] i
mean i just remember him coming out of
louisville you know
and him being the big thing here in the
new york area oh he's a second round
pick but he's really a first round
talent type guy there was all this talk
here and listen
i don't know i don't i got i mean i
don't remember anything i was obsessed
with football at that point in my life
like
nothing like i yeah i don't remember any
what was it would you say eight tds nine
picks
20 20. as the as
as the career so yes that's like
not very good certainly that was one of
those that happened so quick there was
all these expectations and just like uh
neil o'donnell it was gone in like two
years
he was taking one pick
right after brett favre in the 1991
draft
ron wolfe who was in the jets front
office at the time
was hoping and wishing and praying that
would make it down to that spot and the
jets would have taken favre in 1991 not
browning nagel and nagel was indeed a
disaster
2013 draft was it 2013 gino smith second
round pick new york jets total disaster
it just it it just was you know it's
easy to say look mark sanchez won four
playoff games all on the road i think
that's still a record i
it was geno smith the replacement for
sanchez that was a disaster for the jets
never should have picked him never
worked out i know he's still in the nfl
he's the backup to russell wilson he's
still getting a paycheck i respect that
but as a starter it just it never
happened and when you get picked as high
as he did early part of round two
it was uh it was not good yeah the
notorious sucker punch well that's what
i mean ikn and paulie right uh over some
stupid money
it was like did you reimburse him for
his flight to go to a football camp they
got into an argument he got sucker
punched that that was the punch line and
the punctuation for geno smith's time
with the new york jets yeah i mean a lot
like kind of like the brownie nagel
thing it was like oh man we got this guy
in the top of the second round who's
really a first round talent this is
gonna be awesome and yeah i mean again
it was it was weird the team wasn't good
he certainly didn't help himself and
that was the end right there with that
punch it was like bye bye all right see
you later ryan fitzpatrick took over and
they went 10-6 right um all right
man i mean
the last one it's one of the usc
quarterbacks
all right i mean
i'll go with sam darnold you can go
either one even though like you said
sanchez
he won some playoff games but the way he
was touted was like it's guaranteed uh
but sam darnold was the same way and he
didn't win any playoff games so i'll go
with sam darnold it's sammy the savior i
mean he's gonna save us it's it's don't
worry about anything else everybody we
got sam donald that's over in fact hey
guys don't even sign anybody on offense
he's so good he'll do it himself we
don't need receivers or running backs or
offensive line oh wait yeah you do that
was stupid but i just think the hype
around sam darnold and all that was too
high and it led jets fans to misbelieve
in something that wasn't going to really
happen
yeah i think the level of disappointment
is driven by what you expected and with
sam darnold going from six to three to
get him the second quarterback off the
board in a draft that was full of great
quarterbacks and there have been
multiple guys from that class who have
been great quarterbacks that the jets
didn't take josh allen and lamar jackson
it does make it disappointing i'm going
to go farv as my last one the guy who
would have been the first round pick in
1991 by the jets if the falcons hadn't
taken brett favre later comes to the
jets in 2008 with a ton of hype
big deal they had the the the press
conference and everything's going to be
great and they get out of the gates and
everything's good and then it all falls
apart and they don't even go to the
place
for one year and they they were eight
and three and they won a third i think
it was a thursday night game against the
titans
rolling we were undefeated that was our
10-0 titans the 10-0 titans and brett
favre and company came to town and yeah
yeah uh yeah they they they beat our
butt that day we were worn out from the
win streak and it like almost fell apart
from that point on they got that win and
everybody was like whoa they beat the
titans are brett favre and the jets the
best team in the afc and it just it it
got worse and worse from that point on
jet's historian matt casey points out it
was a thursday night win over the
patriots and then the win over the
titans i remember asking the league 2008
what happens if the jets and giants are
both hosting conference championship
games because remember until plexiko
burris
self shot himself right
thanksgiving weekend the giants were on
track for the one seed the jets were on
track for the one seed it was a real
question yeah that that that
they're gonna what do we do we're gonna
have to split the conference
championships off over two days yeah
because there's no way you can clear out
the stadium that'd be good play the
other game
all right let's see what happened
maybe it will one of these days you got
four teams now in two states
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports